สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียมวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะค่ะปึ๊บหาปากกา
ก่อนได้ค่ะวัน
อังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 26 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะ
พ.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูเรียม
ตอนนี้ 900
น 3 นค่ะค่ะ 93 นที่ประเทศไทยร้อนมั้ยคะ
ร้อนร้อนมากค่ะตอนเนี้ยแดดส่องอยู่นะเแดด
ส่องเข้ามาียมก็ออแสบตาเอ้าแต่ว่าแดดส่อง
เข้ามาก็แสงไงแสงก็สวยมากๆนะใช่ยอมยอมทน
เพื่อแง
ใช่แล้วที่อเมริกาล่ะคะร้อนมยคะครูหญิงก็
อาทิตย์ที่แล้วอาทิตย์ที่แล้วร้อนมากทุก
วันเนี่ยก็
ประมาณ
36  34  -  36 องเซซร้อนนะร้อนมากร้อน
มากร้อนมากค่ะแต่อาทิตย์นี้เนี่ยก็จะร้อน
น้อยลงเนาก็อฝนตกอย่างวันนี้ก็ฝนตกนะคะ
แล้วที่อเมริกามีแบบพัดลมมีแอร์อะไรแบบ
นี้มั้คะอย่างห้องครูหญิงเนี่ยพัดลมไม่มี
แต่ว่ามีแอร์อก็เปิดแอร์อยู่ใช่ค่ะอแต่
ไม่รู้ว่าคือเหมือนเคยได้ยินว่าบางอันนี้
นิวยอร์กนะที่อื่นไม่แน่ใจนะคะก็แบบบาง
ตึกบางอพาร์ตเมนต์ที่มันแบบมันนานมันเก่า
มากๆ
บางครั้งเขาก็ไม่มีแอร์ค่ะมีแต่ฮีทเตอร์
ใช่ฮีตเตอร์อย่างเดียวเออแต่อย่างของครู
หญิงเนี่ยถ้าฤดูหนาวก็เปลี่ยนเป็น
ฮีทเตอร์ฤดูร้อนก็แอรมันมันมันเปลี่ยนได้
อ๋อในเครื่องเดียวกันเหรอคะใช่ค่ะมันจะมี
ปุ่มแบบว่ามี 2  2 ปุ่มปุ่มข้างบนก็เป็น
ร้อนปุ่มข้างล่างก็เป็นเย็นเอย่างตอนนี้
ของครูหญิงก็กดปุ่มที่มันเป็นเย็นมันก็จะ
มีลมลมเย็นๆออกมาหุยดีจังเลยค่ะก็โอเคนะ
ถ้าไม่มีแอร์เนี่ยก็ต้องมีพัดลมนะมีพัดลม
คือมีพัดลมก็โอเคนะคะครูเรียมมันมันไม่
ได้ร้อนเหมือนกรุงเทพฯอ่ะคือที่กรุงเทพฯ
อ่ะถ้าครูหญิงอยู่กรุงเทพฯอ่ะเวลานอนเปิด
แอร์เปิดพัดลม 2 อย่างเลยคือเปิดแอร์
อย่างเดียวไม่โอเคก็ยังร้อนถ้าไม่เปิด
แอร์เปิดพัดลมอย่างเดียวไม่ไหวค่ะก็ร้อน
ร้อนมากใช่ร้อนมากใช่เออแต่อย่างที่นี่
เนี่ยถ้าไม่มีแอร์มีพระลมมันมันโอเคนะมัน
ไม่ได้ร้อนขนาดนั้นอ
โใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าูหญิงก็ได้ยินมานะคะครู
เรียมเขาก็บอกว่าปีนี้ปีนี้เนี่ยมันร้อน
มากกว่าปกติคือปกติแล้วอ่ะฤดูร้อนเนี่ย
มันก็ร้อนนะคะแต่ว่ามันไม่ได้ร้อนขนาดนี้
อ่ะค่ะครูเรียมอืเมื่อเมื่อวานครูหญิงไป
เดินห้างที่นี่ก็มีห้างนะอ่ะมี
ห้างไม่รู้จำชื่อมีแใช่มั้ยใช่ใช่ค่ะแบบ
เวลาเดินเข้าไปข้างในอ่ะมันจะคล้ายๆกับ
ไอคอนเสสยามอ่ะครูเรียมเคยไปไอคอนสยามใช่
มั้ยคะยังไม่เคยไปเลยค่ะครูหญิงเคยไปแบบั
World ไปสยามอะไรอก็มันก็จะคล้ายๆ
พารากอนน่ะค่ะก็คือแบบชั้น 1 เนาะเวลาเรา
เดินเข้าไปข้างในเนี่ยชั้นที่ 1 มันก็จะ
เป็นร้านที่ขายพวกสิ่งอเค้าเรียกอะไรคะ
ของแบรนด์เนมแพงๆอ่ะแบรนด์แบบหลุยวิกตอง
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยมันก็จะอยู่ชั้นหนึมัน
เหมือนไอคอนสยามเลยอ่ะค่ะใช่แล้วก็แบบ
เมื่อวานวันอาทิตย์คือที่ไทยเอ่อที่ที่
อเมริกาตอนนี้ยังเป็นวันจันทร์เนาะเมื่อ
วานวันอาทิตย์อ่ะค่ะที่ห้างก็คือคนคนเยอะ
มากเพราะว่าคือคือห้างห้างมันจะมีที่นั่ง
ฟรีอ่ะค่ะออเหมือนที่ไทยมีมั้ยอ่ะเหมือน
ไม่ค่อยมีแล้วมั้ยก็มีแต่น้อยนะน้อยนอก
จากจะเข้าไปทานอาหารในร้านอาหารอะไรแบบ
เนี้ยอืแต่อนี้มันจะเป็นที่นั่งแบบนั่ง
นั่งในห้างอ่ะมาเราไม่ต้องไม่ต้องไม่ใช่
ร้านอาหารไม่ใช่ร้านกาแฟอ่ะค่ะอ่าเราก็
นั่งได้เลยมันก็จะมีโต๊ะแล้วก็มีเก้าอี้
แบบ 1  2  3 น่าจะประมาณ 10 กว่าโต๊ะอ่ะ
ค่ะแบบเรียงกันไปอย่างเงี้ยก็คือเต็มทุก
คนนั่งเต็มมากหงรอะไรร้อนใช่มอากาศร้อน
ค่ะอากาศร้อนแน่นอนคุหิงก็เลยคิด
อ๋อคนต่างชาติก็เหมือนคนไทยนะถ้าร้อนก็ไป
หาห้างเดินที่ไหนก็ได้ที่มีแอร์เพราะว่า
ถ้าเกิดอยู่บ้านแล้วแบบอยู่คนเดียวเปิด
แอร์แล้วเปลืองไฟมากเลยนะจ่าข้าวไฟเี่
เยอะมากใช่เยอะใช่อย่างของผู้หญิงอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะคืออันนี้แบบฤดูร้อนน่ะยังไม่รู้
นะเพราะว่าไม่เคยเปิดแอร์ทุกวันอืมเดือน
นี้ละค่ะเดือนที่ 7 เนี่ยที่มันร้อนมากๆ
นะคะก็แบบเปิดแอร์ทุกวันแต่ไม่ได้เปิด
ทั้งวันนะคะไม่ได้เปิดทั้งวันแต่ตอนอ่า
ฤดูหนาวอ่ะค่ะฤดูหนาวช่วงคริสต์มาสปีใหม่
เนี่ยมันต้องเปิดฮีสเตอร์อ่ะค่ะครูเรียม
ถ้าถ้าไม่เปิดอยู่ไม่ได้มันหนาวแบบหนาว
มากๆอืคือแบบเปิดฮีทเตอร์ 1 เดือนนะของ
อันนี้เฉพาะของครูหญิงนะคะเพราะว่าของผู้
หญิงทั้งหมดมันเป็นไฟฟ้าอ่าคือคือที่
อเมริกาค่ะบางคอนโดบางอพาร์เมนน่ะเขาจะ
ใช้แก๊สอ๋อออมกำลังจะถามเรียมคิดว่าเอ๊ะ
เค้าเอาฟืนไปแบบแกสได้หรอแต่เคใช้แก๊สได้
ไม่เหมือนประเทศไทยใช่มยประเทศไทยถ้าเป็น
อพาร์ตเมนเป็นคอนโดมิเนียมเนี่ยห้ามแก๊ส
ใช่เออแต่ที่เนี่ยเ้าจะใช้แก๊สถ้าใช้แก๊ส
มันจะไม่แพงมันจะไม่แพงอ่าแต่ตึกครูหญิง
อ่ะค่ะทั้งหมดเป็นไฟฟ้าก็คือทำอาหารก็
เป็นเตาไฟฟ้าอย่างเงี้ยค่ะแอร์หรือว่า
ฮีทเตอร์ก็เป็นไฟฟ้าแบบเคยเปิดฮีตเตอร์ 1
เดือนทั้งเดือนคือเปิดทั้งวันน่ะไม่ปิด
เลยนะคะไม่ปิดเลยคุณหญิงออกไปข้างนอกก็
เปิด
โห
300 ค่าไฟอ่ะน่าจะประมาณ 300 เหรียญอ่ะ
โหคือเยอะมากเลยคผู้หญิงตอผู้หญิงอยู่คน
เดียวหรือเปล่าหรืออยู่กับเพื่อนหรือไม่ๆ
ๆๆใช่ไม่ได้อยู่คนเดียวค่ะแต่ว่ามันก็มี
ฮีตเตอร์ 1 ตัวฮีตเตอร์ 2 ตัวอ๋อสมมุติ 3
แต่มันไม่ได้แค่ฮีตเตอร์อย่างเดียวอนะคะ
มันก็จะเป็นแบบ
คอมพิวเตอร์ทำอาหารเนาะตู้เย็นทั้งหมดอ่ะ
ที่มันเป็นไฟอ่ะค่ะครูเรียมก็ตอนนั้น
มันค่าค่าไฟแบบเดือนละ 9,000 คือ
แบบแต่ว่าถ้าใครบางคนก็เป็นนะเมเห็นบางคน
เวลาร้อนจริงๆอ่ะค่าไฟก็ประมาณแบบ 6,000
7,000 หรือบางคนก็แพงมากกว่านั้นอยู่ที่
ว่าบ้านหลังใหญ่หรือเปล่าูหญิงอยู่แค่
คอนโดมิเนียมอ่ะค่ะฤดูร้อนน่ะแบบเดือน
เมษายนพฤษภาคมอย่างเงี้ยฤดูร้อนมันรอน
มีนาคมด้วยแล้วกันมีนาคมเมษายนพฤษภาคมค่ะ
ก็ค่าไฟคุณหญิงก็คือ 2,000 ขึ้นนี่คือ
เปิดแอร์แบบเฉพาะตอนกลางคืนก็มีนะอือืแบบ
มันร้อนไงคะเวลาเวลาที่อากาศมันร้อนก็ไม่
รู้จะทำยังไงเนาะก็ไม่เป็นไรนะคะครูหญิง
เวลาที่ครูหญิงอยู่ประเทศไทยฤดูร้อนครู
หญิงก็เปิดแอร์เยอะๆได้แล้วเมื่อไหร่ที่
แบบฤดูหนาวมาถึงครูหญิงก็เอ้าสบายแล้วก็
เสียข้าไฟไ้
ประเทศไทยมีเหรอคะฤดู
น้ำคือรืมจำได้ตอนเด็กๆน่ะมีใช่มั้ยเออ
ใช่ๆครูหญิงอ่ะแค่แค่ครูหญิงอยู่ชลบุรี
อ่ะค่ะฤดูหนาวตอนครูหญิงเด็กๆอ่ะหนาวแบบ
ไม่อยากอาบน้ำไปโรงเรียนเลยนะครูเรียม
จริงไม่อยากอาบน้ำหรือว่าไม่ได้อาบเอ่อ
ไม่อยากอาบแต่อาบอ๋อแต่ไม่อยากอาบน้ำอ่ะ
แล้วบ้านคนไทยสมัยก่อนน่ะค่ะเราอย่างบ้าน
ครูหญิงอ่ะอ่าน้ำมันจะอยู่ในในตุ่ม
อ่ะไม่รู้ว่าบ้านครูเรียมเมื่อก่อนตุ่มมี
ตุ่มน้ำใช่ค่ะมีตุ่มน้ำ
หูตุ่มใสที่มือนะคะผู้หญิงเสิร์ช
Google เมื่อก่อนนะผมนี่อยากพูดเลย
เดี๋ยวเขาจะรู้แบบอายุแบบทันตอนที่แบบ
ห้องน้ำมีตุ่มอยู่ข้างนอกห้องน้ำอ่ะค่ะ
แบบเป็นช่วงที่นานมามากแล้วแบบห้องน้ำก็
มีนะห้องน้ำก็มีอันเนี้ยเป็นห้องน้ำค่ะ
เข้าไปก็มีแบบชักโคกนั่น
แหละแต่ตอนนั้นไม่มีชะโคกเนาเค้าเป็นแบบ
คอห่าเ่ามันมีคอห่านอุ้ยทำไมผู้เรียก
เหมือนผู้หญิง
เลยนักเรียนจะนึกออกมั้ยอ่ะว่าคอหารคือ
อะไรเดี๋ยวๆกูหญิงเปิดให้ดูก็ได้เมื่อกี
นี้กูหญิงเสิร์ชคำว่าตุ่มน้ำอ่ะแล้วมัน
ขึ้นมันขึ้นแบบเหมือนเหมือนโลกที่มันเป็น
อยู่ตอนเยค่ะุเลี้ยมให้หาอะไรนะคอหารใช่
มั้ยใช่ๆคอหารคิดว่าแบบไม่ค่อยเห็นแล้ว
นะคือตอนนี้เนี่ยไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีค่ะขณะ
ที่บ้านผู้หญิงที่ที่ชลบุรีตอนนี้ก็ก็ไม่
มีนะคะี่ใช่ใช่นักเรียนเนี่ยอเรียกว่า
ส้วมคอห่านใช่ค่ะเพราว่าเค้าเขียนข้าง
ล่างด้วยนะครูหญิงเบอกว่าตำนานเออไหนอัน
นั้นเหรอตำนานส้วมคอ
ห่าเพราะว่าแบบจริงๆถ้าแบบคนไทยบางคนที่
อยู่กรุงเทพฯอ่ะหรือแบบบางคนอยู่ชลบุรีก็
ได้นะครุหญิงคิดว่าถ้าอายุประมาณครูเรียม
อ่ะเค้าก็ไม่รู้จักคออาหารก็มีนะใช่ใช่ๆ
พอเา้าแบบใช่ใช้แบบกดชักโคร่กันแล้วเออ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าบ้านผู้หญิงสมัยก่อนก็เป็นคอ
ห่าเหมือนกันแล้วก็อาบน้ำแบบตุ่มน้ำอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะแล้วตุ่มน้ำอ่ะมันทำมาจากดินใช่
มั้ยเขาจะปั้นน่ะเอาดินมาปั้นให้มันเป็น
ตุ่มน้ำออแล้วเวลาเราเอาน้ำใส่อ่ะมันมี
น้ำอยู่อ่ะค่ะตุ่มอ่ะมันเป็นดินเวลาเอา
น้ำใส่เนี่ยน้ำมันจะเย็นแบบเย็นมากถึงแม้
ว่าถ้าประเทศไทยร้อนน้ำมันก็เย็นแล้วฤดู
หนาวน้ำมันจะแบบเย็นมาเย็นมากๆเลยนะคะ
เย็นเหมือนเอาไปใส่ตู้เย็นน่ะนัก
เรียนใช่เออแบบไม่อยากอาบน้ำอ่ะแบบเทคนิค
เลยคือต้องตักน้ำขึ้นมา 1 ขันแล้วก็เอา
แบบใส่ให้เรารู้สึกแบบอือโอเคเราชินกับ
น้ำเย็นๆแล้วแล้วก็ 1  2  3 พอไม่อาแบบ
แบบนี้หือเปล่า 1 อ่ะไปข้างหลังอ่ะ 1  2
ไปข้างหลัง 3 ไปข้างหลังตัวเองไม่เปียก 1
ตัวอันนั้นไม่ต้องอ่าวก็ใช่แต่มันหนาว
จริงๆนะนักเรียนอาจจะคิดแบบประเทศไทยมี
ด้วยเหรอาจังหวัดมีอืมีๆๆตอนตอนเด็กๆอ่ะ
มีแบบเดี๋ยวมีใช่ค่ะที่เรียมถามครูหญิง
ว่าครูหญิงได้แบบอาบน้ำหรือเปล่าเพราะว่า
เรียมเนี่ยมีสถิติประมาณแบบ 7 วันน่ะที่
ไม่อาบน้ำเพราะว่ามันหนาว
มากอือแต่ก็เข้าใจนะว่าแบบมันหนาวมากๆเรา
ก็ไม่ต้องอาบน้ำทั้งเช้าทั้งเย็นก็ได้นะ
ใช่มันจะคันนักเรียนจะตกใจหรือเปล่าเฮ้ย
ประเทศไทยมีแบบนี้ด้วยหรอใช่นักเรียนแล้ว
แบบตอนครูหญิงเด็กๆมันหนาวขนาดว่าเราต้อง
ผิงไฟนะคะใช่อออูแต่ว่ามันเปลี่ยนแปลงไป
เร็วมากเลยเนาะอืใช่แบบตอนนี้ก็น่าจะเป็น
แบบเค้าเรียกอะไรอ่ะโลกร้อนใช่มั้ยตอนนี้
เนี่ยมันเป็นช่วงของแบบโลกร้อนก็คืออย่าง
ออย่างประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็ไม่ได้ร้อนใช่มั้ย
คะแต่ฝนตกมากๆฝนตกมากแล้วก็ฤดูหนาวเนี่ย
รู้สึกว่าจะไม่มีอ่ะไม่มีบางทีมีฤดูหนาว
อือใช่หรือว่าแบบบางทีฤดูหนาวก็หนาวมากๆ
อ่ะบางทีฤดู
ร้อนบางวันก็หนาวอย่างเงี้ยค่ะมันมาจาก
แบบโลกร้อนใช่มยโลกของเราเนี่ยมันร้อนมาก
ขึ้นอืก็เหมือนกันค่ะครูเรียมเหมือนที่
อเมริกาเมื่อก่อนเขาใช้แต่ฮีสเตอร์ใช่่
มั้ยอเพราะว่าแบบอากาศที่นั่นหนาวมากตอน
นี้ไม่มีใครจำเป็นต้องใช้แอร์เออไม่
มีเหมือนที่อังกฤษน่ะเพื่อนเรียมเล่าให้
ฟังว่าที่อังกฤษอุณหภูมิประมาณ 28 องศา
สำหรับเขาเนี่ยคือร้อนมากๆอือแล้วก็ช่วง
ที่ผ่านมาก็คือมีคนตายเพราะว่าอากาศ 28
องศาคือธรรมดาเ้าร้อนไม่ถึงขนาดนั้นไง
แล้วเปิดพัดลมเปิดพัดลมมันก็ยังร้อนอยู่
แล้วก็ไม่มีแอร์อ
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าครูหญิงมีเพื่อนน่ะเค้า
อยู่แบบอีกโซนนึงของนิวยอร์กอ่ะค่ะที่มัน
จะเก่ามันจะเก่าก็คือแบบคือนิวยอร์กมันจะ
อายุนานมากๆใช่มยมันเป็นเมืองเก่าเมือง
นึงในอเมริกามันก็จะมีตึกที่เป็น
อพาร์ตเมนต์คอนโดมิเนียมที่แบบอายุมาก
กว่า 100 ปีอ่ะค่ะ
โหใช่แล้วแบบคือมันจะเป็นโซนนั้นน่ะบางคน
เขาจะชอบไงคะมันจะเป็นเหมือนเมืองเก่า
เรียกอย่าเงี้ยใช่แล้วมันก็จะเป็นแบบที่
มันเป็นอิฐแดงอ่ะครูเรียง
อ๋อแบบเยค่ะถ้าเกิดเป็นบ้านเราก็แถวๆ
อยุธยาหรือเปล่าใช่ๆมันจะเป็นแบบเออใช่
ค่ะแบบมันจะเป็นอย่างเงี้ยตึกมันจะเป็น
อิดสีแดงบางคนเขาจะชอบแบบนี้ไงมันสวยใช่
มันสวยมันไม่ใช่เหมือนคอนโดในกรุงเทพฯอ่ะ
ค่ะอ่าอย่างแบบเพื่อนผู้หญิงเขาอยู่แบบ
เนี้ยค่ะมันก็จะมีมีแค่ฮีตเตอร์ฮีทเตอร์
เท่านั้นอ่าพอแบผู้หญิงบอกว่าอ๋อของผู้
หญิงเนี่ยเป็นฮีทเตอร์ก็ได้เป็นแอร์ก็ได้
เขาก็บอกว่าออ้ก็ดีนะฤดูร้อนเราก็เปิด
แอร์ได้ใช่แบบไม่ต้องแบบทนร้อนน่ะค่ะ
เพราะว่าอย่างครูเรียมพูดถึงอังกฤษอ่ะครู
หญิงก็ได้ยินข่าวใช่มยว่าประมาณอาทิตย์
ที่แล้วมยคะว่าอังกฤษเนี่ยร้อน 40 ององศา
ใช่มั้ยโหอาจจะเป็นแบบบางพื้นที่ใช่ที่
ที่เค้าบอกว่าเอ่อสนามบินฮิอ่าที่แบบไม่
รู้เค้าเรียกอะไรรันเวยหรอหรืออะไรสัก
อย่างที่มันแบบมันร้อนมากๆอ่ะเออไม่ไม่
แน่ใจนะว่าฮีหรือเปล่าแต่ว่าจำได้ว่าได้
ยินข่าวว่าอาทิตย์ที่แล้วอ่าอังกฤษร้อน
มากอื 40 ก็เข้าใจนะคะเพราะว่านิวยอร์กก็
ร้อนมากๆอืแล้วเก็เขาก็บอกเหมือนกันว่า
จริงๆมันไม่ได้ร้อนขนาดนี้นะแต่ปีนี้มัน
ร้อนร้อนมากใช่ร้อนมากกว่าทุกปีอืแล้ว
หลายๆที่ที่เคยหนาวมากๆแบบเนี้ยมันก็แบบ
รู้สึกว่าร้อนมากขึ้นนะร้อนยุโรปก็ร้อน
ใช่มั้ยคะปีเนี้ยใช่เมื่อก่อนที่บอกว่า
หนาวมากหิมะตกอะไรประมาณเนี้ยอืตอนนี้ภู
เขาหิมะก็มีไม่ค่อยเยอะนะใช่ค่ะแบบอย่าง
เอ่ออะไรนะกรีนแลนด์มยกรีนแลนด์ที่มันจะ
มีน้ำแข็งเยอะๆใช่มั้ยคะมันก็ร้อนแล้วก็
น้ำแข็งมันก็ละลายเป็นน้ำอย่างเงี้ยคือ
เขาก็บอกว่ามันมาจากโลกร้อนเนาะเหมือนเรา
อ่าอาจจะใช้พลาสติกเยอะๆใช่มั้ยขับรถมากๆ
หรือว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ของ
เราใช่ก๊าซทั้งอย่างมันก็ทำให้แบบโลกร้อน
มากขึ้นอือใช่ตอนเที่เรียมแบบมีบ้านอยู่
ในสวนใช่มยตอนแรกเรียมตั้งใจว่าจะไม่ติด
แอร์เพราะว่าเวลาเราติดแอร์เนี่ยมันเย็น
เยข้างในบ้านแต่ข้างนอกบ้านน่ะเราจะปล่อย
ลมร้อนออกไปอือแล้วกำลังนึกถึงว่าแบบแล้ว
สัตว์อย่างอื่นน่ะที่เขาแบบไม่สามารถอยู่
ในที่เย็นๆไม่สามารถเลือกได้เหมือนเราอ่ะ
เขาจะอยู่ยังไงอืใช่มเรียมก็เลยแบบแต่ตอน
นี้เรียมก็คิดอยู่ว่าเลียมก็น่าจะแย่
เหมือนกันถ้าเกิดไม่ติดแอร์ตอน
เยใช่ๆค่ะเพราะว่าแบบผู้หญิงเคยมีอาทิตย์
นึงอ่ะที่ไปเดินแบบมันก็ร้อนนะครูเรียม
แต่มันไม่ร้อนขนาดนี้แล้วมี 1 อาทิตย์ที่
ไปเดินแบบเค้าเรียกอะไรครูเรียมชอบอ่ะ
เดินป่ามยเดินป่าไปเดินป่าใช่ค่ะแล้วแบบ
ผู้หญิงก็เอาน้ำเนี่ยไป 1 ขวดนะอย่าง
เงี้ยไม่พอเพราะว่าแบบมันร้อนแบบร้อนมาก
อ่ะเออเหนือก็ออกเยอะใช่ค่ะเออแต่ว่าก็
ไม่ได้รู้ว่าอ๋ออ่าอเมริกาเนี่ยร้อนเป็น
ยังไงเพราะคุหญิงก็ไม่เคยมาแบบฤดูร้อน
จริงๆอ่ะร้อนแบบฤดูร้อนเเคยอันนี้ถฤดู
ร้อนอยู่มั้ยตอนนี้ใช่ค่ะใช่ค่ะก็เาจะ
ประมาณเดือนมิถุนายนกรกฎาคมศหไม่ใช่
พฤษภาค
มั้งไม่แน่ใจนะคะแต่ว่าตอนเนี้ยร้อนเดือน
หน้าร้อนแล้วก็จะค่อยๆเปลี่ยนและอ่าเดือน
ที่ 9 เงี้ยก็จะไม่ร้อนแล้วใช่ใช่ประเทศ
ไทยเดือนนี้ร้อนเดือนหน้าก็ร้อนเดือนต่อ
ไปก็ร้อนร้อนใช่ค่ะนั่นแหละก็เพราะว่ามัน
เป็นโลกร้อนเคะนักเรียนก็เคยก็เลยไม่เคย
เจอประเทศไทยฤดูหนาวเหมือนครูหญิงกับครู
เรียมอ่ะที่บอกว่าตื่นมาไม่อยากอาบน้ำไป
โรงเรียนอ่ะค่ะแล้วก็ไม่ไม่อาบน้ำถึง 7
วันน่ะนักเรียนก็คงไม่เคยเจอคนไทยมีแบบ
นี้หรอใช่ใช่ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าตอนนี้มันไม่ไม่
มีแล้วไงเนาะภาวะโลกร้อนเอ้ยไม่ใช่อากาศ
หนาวแบบนั้นน่ะไม่มีแล้วใช่ต้องไปภูเขา
เท่านั้นนะคะก็หลายๆประเทศก็เปลี่ยนเป็น
ร้อนเหมือนกันใช่มยเราก็เลยต้องแบบช่วย
กันดูแลโลกของเราอืว่าเหมือนครูเรียมไม่
อยากมีแอร์ใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าแบบมันก็ปล่อย
ความร้อนก๊าซอะไรออกมาใช่ๆแต่ไม่รู้จะทน
ได้นานแค่ไหนนะค่ะอือถ้าผู้หญิงก็คือไม่
ได้
ค่ะถ้านอนต้องมีแอร์แต่ถ้าแบบทำงานอย่าง
เงี้ยไม่มีไม่เป็นไรโอเคชนได้อืเพราะว่า
จะได้นอนไม่หลับไงเพราะว่ามันร้อนก็ทำงาน
ไปเรื่อย
ๆเนาะวันนี้เราก็มาคุยเกี่ยวกับเอ่ออากาศ
ร้อนนะคะใช่นัก
ฟังวันนี้หมดเวลาเราด้วยค่ะครูหญิงใช่ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวเราก็ขอตัวไปอาบน้ำก่อนนะคะใช่ร้อน
มากจะได้ไม่ร้อนเออนเอ๊หรือว่าจะหนาวดี
หนาวสัก 4 วันอุ๊ยหนาวก็ดีนะยังไงหนาวห่ม
ผ้าได้นะ
คะโอเคต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะครุหญิงลาไป
ก่อนนะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ
อ